guys before you enjoy this fantastic
episodes which is gonna take a few
seconds to remind you that we love to
hear your feedback on everything we do
here the guests the interviews the
subjects that we discuss and the best
way to give us that feedback is through
our partners QT com what we do there is
we put out a question and some polls
every week and we will be reading out
those answers that you give us on our
live streams every single week so it's a
way for you to interact with us and we'd
love you to get stuck in with that
absolutely and we really really wanted
to hear your opinions on everything
about the episode what you enjoyed what
you found controversial what you didn't
like if you're going to comment about my
weight shut your [ __ ] face we don't
need to hear it alright and I please
keep those coming I enjoy this so much
but apart from that that is a reason why
we have partnered with QT because we
think it's an effective way for people
to share their ideas their views their
opinions without all the boil and
nonsense of Twitter and all the rest of
it so if you want to have your opinion
heard and if you want to be able to
share your ideas in a space which
supports free speech go on to QT so this
week as you will see the conversation we
have with dr. Mike Martin is all about
why we fight why men behave the way that
they do and one of the things we wanted
to do is host the conversation on QT
about masculinity it's an issue that's
very important it's very much in the
news right now so please head over there
once you've seen their passado during
the episode and give us your feedback
you know it's amazing the degree to
which very simple things that's
biologists have understood for say 50
years haven't translated into our study
of politics
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet or the subjects they know
nothing about trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we are C
experts are absolutely fantastic guests
this week is a veteran of the war in
Afghanistan
he's a research fellow at King's College
London researching war studies and he is
the author of this brilliant book why we
fight dr. Mike Martin welcome to
trigonometry hey how you doing and I've
got your name right as I just fight
anyone who's watching this we're
recording this the day after the
election so I'm incredibly hungover
Francis's incredibly disappointed that
you kid didn't win so listen your book
is absolutely incredible absolutely
fascinating talking about why people
fight but before we get into that tell
us a little bit about who are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life abridged version
yeah so I took biology you know a
university first and I thought maybe
I'll become a research scientist I
thought that for about 10 minutes until
I look at the lives that research
scientists had and then I went traveling
for three years I lived in South America
my cell across the South Atlantic and
then I joined the army mm-hmm and I was
in the Army for six years I learned push
T which is the language in southern
Afghanistan I'm in Helmand with the
British were and I spent two years in
Helmand working as a political officer
in fact I was the first political
officer for the British Army so I
developed that whole I sort of pioneered
and developed that role for the British
military and then after that I've done
various jobs but remaining in conflicts
I've worked in in Somalia lived in
Somalia also in in Myanmar worked on
other conflicts
and all good tourist destination we went
to Somalia if he wanted conflict just
got into Croydon on a Friday night yeah
all right so I I've worked in Somaliland
right which is the what was the old
British protectorate yes southern
smuggled issue was the Italian bit yeah
and I live in Stepney in East London and
I put the Somali interest office into
Google because they're not they declared
themselves a state but they're not
actually snake non-recognized them but I
needed a visa to go and work there I
lived in a little flat in alligator and
I realized that the the visa office for
Somaliland was above my Tesco's Metro in
Stepney because there's a huge community
of Somalis in Whitechapel and all the
Somalis in the UK are in the port cities
because they joined the British Merchant
Navy in the 1800s when the smile and
Protectorate was was you know British
protectorate and then they settled in
all the port cities they did their 20
years and then just got off the boat and
settled wherever they got to so the
first mosque in cardiff first mosque in
the UK was in Cardiff and Somali more
skiing on earth so you see these links
that started hundreds of years ago
created diaspora in the UK and then
these conflicts are still ongoing and
they're these huge links to any number
mean that's just one example I'm giving
you but actually you see it in any
number of countries around the world
where Britain or France also has this
has these continuing links to conflicts
often that we're not aware of like how
if I asked you know your average person
in the UK for answers to them it's a
huge part of the history but anyway
sorry I interrupted you just to make a
little joke just so you you went to work
there and you've travelled obviously
incredibly widely and now you're a
research fellow
King's College London the war studies
department and your book really talks
about why it is that we have conflict
why it is the human beings fight but you
yourself served in Afghanistan tell us
about that what was that like
so there's this official narrative of
the war in Afghanistan which is and is
still sealed in media today and it's you
know very broadly it's a kind of
black-white narrative there's a
government that you know is legitimate
elections or that kind of stuff you know
UN supports it and the West the
coalition America and his allies are
supporting that legitimate government
and then against them is is that this
movement called the Taliban who are evil
and girls rights and they sell drugs
suddenly you know so there's a kind of
good bad very simplistic dichotomy but
actually when you get to places like
Helmand or all right you know how was
just a good example is this an extreme
case Afghanistan but the rest of
Afghanistan is the same stuff it's not
that dichotomy
it's not a black/white conflict it's a
kind of multifocal civil war between
different tribes and families and
different drugs militias or landowners
and actually what drives the conflict on
the ground level where we know why does
somebody pull the trigger of a
Kalashnikov at that level its land its
water its feuds between grandparents
that echoed down the generations it's
tribal power blocs
vying for control of the drugs trade
that's what's driving the conflict it's
not these big ideological this
ideological schism that we understand
from the media and actually often groups
both on the government side so people in
the police for instance or militias are
attached to the government and on you
know the Taliban side change sides all
the time so Monday they will be on the
government side and the anti-government
side and what that tells us is that
eight survivals most important as you
would expect after 40 years of war but
it also tells us that people are out to
ensure that they protect the family's
land or the money they make from the
drugs crop and the selection of
ideological labels and really
conveniences to help them achieve those
much more important pragmatic aims so
why is it that we're fed this narrative
then why is it that you know but public
service broadcasts are like the BBC puts
forward a narrative which you're saying
is false
it's really interesting so after I left
the army I did you know quite a lot of
journalism while working with
journalists writing articles on
Afghanistan and something used to
consistently come up which was that the
journalists living in work in
Afghanistan or very close as studying
the conflicts understood this they might
not have had as much detail as I had you
know I wrote my PhD on it and I you know
I spoke push to but they understood they
understood that it wasn't this you know
black-white narrative but when they
submitted their 700 words to newspaper X
or spoke with their editors you know for
broadcast and Y without fail the editor
would say no that doesn't fit the
narrative of the conflict because in the
UK particularly there's only so much
foreign news that is going to get into
the news cycle and there's only enough
this might be one Afghan story a day
right for example when the conflict was
its height in 2012 we had 10,000 British
troops there probably if at lucky one
Afghan story a day and if a British
trooper died that would be that story
you're right
and apart from that there were only a
few narratives so there was the kind of
drugs crop narrative there was kind of
the girls education narrative which
which actually was one of the probably
the thing that was the most successful
about the Western intervention in
Afghanistan and so there were a number
of sort of always cliched narratives
that editors had as their filter because
how complex can you get in 700 words and
yes people did long form and so on and
so forth but not many people read long
form like the main news narratives were
had this very simplistic filter because
people don't you know people spent four
minutes a day on average on UK politics
let alone a war in another country that
people don't really understand why we're
there so people are saying that we
should have got we shouldn't have got
involved in Afghanistan and it created
the wave of terrorism that we see
nowadays yeah is that true
not really no I think
in it when when the Afghan mujahideen
were fighting the Russians in the 1980s
that attracted quite a lot of
international volunteers from say Egypt
or whatever and once the and the Gulf
states and and that jihadi both people
came there and funding oh yeah the CIA
as well from absolutely but also from
the Gulf states yes what happened when
the Russians left there's a lot of those
volunteers went back to Chechnya was the
Algeria and so in the early 90s you see
a number of Islamist inspired either
kind of governments falling or you know
rebellions or you know said that that
was an earlier stage of the Afghan
government's the same conflict these are
not separate conflicts Afghanistan has
been experiencing a civil war since 1978
at least right so the West intervening
of 2001 absolutely didn't create that
wave of terrorism and then the your
other question was should we've got
involved I think I think again it's to
look in more detail at the Afghan
conflict there were there were two
decisions about the level of three
decisions about the level of Western
involvement in Afghanistan one was do we
go in after the Twin Towers and I think
broadly most people accept that that was
justified because the you know song bin
Laden was being given shelter by the
Taliban
except show such I think that what
evidence was overwhelming that Osama bin
Laden was involved and that America's
warned them and I think most people
accept that that was probably justified
mistake number one
was in sort of 2004 five was deciding
rather than I don't know either either
handing over to a UN management of the
country they decided that NATO was going
to get involved in spread troops
garrison troops around the country and
that was a terrible idea and
particularly you know one of the worst
aspects of that was putting the British
in Helmand British you've got history
and Helmand like everywhere else
so if you think about the south of
Afghanistan the road through Hellmann's
so on the east of helmet is Kandahar and
on the west of holding his head arts and
that road runs from Iran down to the
subcontinent okay
and that was the same in the 1800s so
when the British invaded in the 1840s
and in the 1880s they did two pronged
push into Afghanistan once over the
Khyber Pass to Kabul and once over the
pass
just south of Canal to take Kandahar and
when you take Kandahar to defend
Kandahar the easy way to defend Kandahar
is to stick troops in goresh which is
what we did both times Qureshi is the
main city in Helmand and the reason we
put them in Qureshi is because that's
the only fair weather crossing of the
river Helmand so that is how you hold
that entire line from Iran to India what
was British India there was now Pakistan
so we put troops in there there were
tribal rebellions in Hillman's the
Battle of Maiwand was just fought
outside help and I mean everyone says oh
that's a great Afghan victory no it
wasn't that was a victory of the alazai
and the news I two of the three biggest
tribes in Helmand and when we came back
to Helmand in 2006 and said we're coming
here for reconstruction the al-azhar
Lenore's I said doesn't work and because
they have a you know the how mandy's are
mostly illiterate it's about 10 percent
illiteracy at the beginning of the you
know in 2001 eight percent literacy half
a percent for women they have an oral
history culture and it's from my first
book an intimate war was about and not
only did they have those narratives of
we the Amazon and all's I stood up they
also knew who the leaders of those
rebellions were so Abu Bakr horn was the
alazai leader his great-great
grandchildren were still horns in up in
the north of helping someone became you
know resistance commanders against the
British like it was a that was a
catastrophic catastrophic mistake and it
comes from a complete misreading our own
history and the irony is
you know we have the British Library
with 14 million books in it and all the
records of all the political officers
British political office at 1700 1800
nobody read any of that and the
illiterate old man these event they're
all history culture were well aware much
more aware of our own history than us
yeah there's fascinating stuff but
listen let's move on to talk about why
we fight because what you talk about in
the book is a much broader look at
conflict and why human beings engage in
warfare and conflict more generally yeah
why do we fight why do we engage in
conflict so humans have evolved like
every other animal on the planet right
we are part of the animal kingdom and
we've evolved to increase our chance of
surviving and original reproducing
alright this is kind of standard stuff
and so the question you have to answer
when people fighting wars is what's the
evolutionary advantage of fighting wars
because there's a huge death rate and
huge death rates I mean let me give you
an example of how big the death rates
are in the First World War the French
the cohort of French men that fought so
say sixteen to about thirty-five a third
of them died a third that is that in any
other world would be known as a negative
selection pressure yeah okay so why does
war exist and actually that death rate
is probably compares favorably to what
the death rates were like from conflicts
in say the Stone Age were even higher
and so what you've got to do is look for
mechanisms that humans have that drive
the to do things that are of an
evolutionary advantage but then
unfortunately also results in war and
and there are two really obvious
contenders one of them is the pursuit of
social status and the other one is this
need to belong and the pursuit of social
status particularly for men has a huge
evolutionary advantage humans have been
you know we're mostly monogamous now but
actually in our history there was much
much much more polygamy and so good old
days yeah absolutely
and therefore they don't believe in
polygamy yeah anyway carry on so yeah
think about think about polygamy like
this yeah okay if the could be the
higher of the social rank you get as a
man this is the pecking order more
actually you get yeah actually yeah yeah
and you're shooting at so if the top 50%
of men have two wives the bottom 50%
have none yeah so this is a massive
eeveelution any selection pressure to
get in we had jeffrey miller the
evolutionary psychologist on the show
making precisely at this point yeah so
the competition for social status
essentially for men in an evolution race
is actually worth it even if there's a
30% chance of being killed exact because
the the bounty that you get potentially
at least is so great
evolution can never tell us what it
affects will it have on that individual
yeah what evolution tells us is across
thousands of generations yes and across
millions of people what the averages
will be and if say the average death
rate from war because of the drive
towards social status and I'm plucking
these figures out there but just to give
an example you know if the death rate is
3 out of 10 from war but the advantages
of that same mechanism that drive social
sectors are 4 out of 10 then that
mechanism will remain in the gene pool
yes yeah and it's the same with
belonging right there's a who know was
the most interesting part of the book
because I think most people will be
aware of the first thing that we've
talked about but the idea that people
fight and are prepared to go to war and
be killed and maimed in order to belong
to some kind of tribe is fascinating to
me talk more about that so whilst while
social status is a
positive thing you're trying to attain
you know the higher you have your social
status the more as you said the more
action you get right but belonging is
actually the opposite so you've got to
think back to where humans did most of
their cognitive evolution which was on
the African savannah basically between
about eighty and fifty thousand years
ago there was a huge burst of cognitive
evolution and about fifty thousand years
ago we have what's called the cultural
explosion so our work and all that
stuff's not so bad and in that
environment human has lived in groups of
less than thirty kinship related maybe
few non kin members but that was the
that was a group right and these bands
were fighting each other and they were
surviving in the environment that had
lots of wild animals and in that
environment not having a social group to
belong to was an almost immediate death
sentence yeah okay and so these feelings
that we have towards belonging to
something whether it's a tribe you know
chiefdom an ancient empire and modern
nation-state a political party a
football team acquire these all
triggered by the same mechanism which
forces us to seek out a social group
something to belong to and and we do
that you know as I said because to not
have a social group in in evolutionary
terms and don't forget we still start
now in 2020 with these mechanisms that
we evolved that we've evolved over the
last you know two million years as
hominids to not to not belong and was a
death sentence and if you look at how
that mechanism evolved it it gives you
real insight into both politics and war
so think about it this way if you have
this mechanism which causes you to seek
blogging yeah to find people to come
together to close you in with that only
works if as well as creating a drive
towards an in-group if it creates an out
group at the same time you can't have
one without the other and why well
because if the mechanism evolved that
said trust everyone put everyone towards
you making
part of your group then another genotype
would arise in the population that said
take advantage of those people are
trusting all the time so the only way
you can have a mechanism that says trust
other people is if you say trust the
in-group and don't trust the out-group
and this mechanism which has a hormonal
pathway which is regulated by a hormone
called oxytocin and status is regulated
by testosterone but this hormonal
pathway does two things it creates
feelings of empathy and trust within the
in-group at the same time that it did it
derogative is an out-group and creates
distrust and what you know has also
other effects like you can see
heterogeneity within the in-group but
you you homogenize the out-group what we
michael authoring in society yeah you
know these are very basic mostly
subconscious evolutionary mechanisms
that we've evolved for very good reasons
both status and belonging but that have
the side effects of driving us towards
group conflicts it's a fascinating
explanation of why Francis is racist
calling me racist anyway well you see
I'm just proud of it you know you're not
thanks to our returning sponsors a b-52
dot-com
you can now Sampa ate delicious craft
beers for absolutely free all you have
to do guys is head over to beer 52 comm
forward slash trigger and cover the
postage which is 4 pounds 95 what's more
is a trigonometry fan you'll get two
extra beers for free so that's ten free
beers which means you'll be able to stay
in getting smashed whilst listening to
hate speech well as its otherwise known
Christmas in the francis foster
household
you've never been tomorrow so christmas
how did you not all you got to do guys
is head over to beer 50 to calm forward
slash trigger and get your case
absolutely free i had some of the other
day on one of our live streams really
enjoyed
some great variety of beers in there you
will enjoy too so make use of this
fantastic opportunity and you normally
only drinks polonium tea right so um
what we do so what I found very very
interesting good touching on the hormone
oxytocin is essentially we're not even
aware that we're being driven like that
so every time we join a choir we were a
football shirt we we sing together
national anthem you hear the national
anthem it's almost like we're getting a
hormonal rush which drives us to to
create these bonds and these groups
either need to have the experience in
you know singing aquire football match
whatever where you get a tingle down
your spine yeah yeah well that that is
that pathway yeah that's you feeling a
sense of belonging and it triggers the
oxytocin pathway that then triggers a
bunch of positive hormones that then
give you those feelings of pleasure so
by that logic if somebody doesn't get as
big a hit from that as other people they
wouldn't feel as as inclined to be part
of a group right right and and you know
it's amazing the degree to which very
simple things that biologists have
understood for say 50 years haven't
translated into our study of politics so
for instance you know most traits how
tall you are that's a physical trait or
a behavioral trait
whether you feel this sense of belonging
they tend to fall on a kind of bell
curve right so most people are in the
median they you know they're about five
and a half foot six foot over the
average height is and they feel a kind
of medium sense of belonging but of
course you get extremes you get some
people who can't feel a sense of
belonging at all and you get some who
are you know mega passionate and these
are the kind of political activists for
a political party or instance and
another thing that you know another
aspect of biology that sort of well
under certain bar is it doesn't
translate at all into public debate is
this idea that every traits whether it's
physical or behavioral
as a result of your genetic inheritance
multiplied by environmental factors this
nature nurture argument is is nonsense
it's both every single traits has both
and some have slightly more heritability
so genetic component some have slightly
more environmental but they are but both
involved both genes and environment
involved in behavioral traits and in
physical traits so you're saying that
some people essentially might have a
genetic predisposition to extremism
of one sort or another I think that okay
so trying to justify them in this is a
debate that is not ad yeah okay because
and the reason it's not Ed's and you
know the the the gender debate is
another example is it gonna come to that
yeah absolutely this is this is not it
and there's a very good reason why it's
not that okay it after the sort of
eugenics movement in the 30s and you
know that peaking with Nazism affected
me there was a backlash within
scholarship because you've got this two
views right is either genetically
determined extremes of you sites
genetically determined or it's all
social imprinting we're born as a blank
slate and then everything is kind of
social imprinting right and as a
reaction against eugenics and the Nazi
movement scholarship moved right on to
this tabula rasa blank slate view of
human Commons but it's not that you know
as I've said it wasn't over correct
understand it was an overcorrection and
it's back to your question about you
know is there a genetic heritability
involved in terrorism okay so I'm not
aware of any data that supports that
view okay but that's probably because
people haven't asked that question
because it's hard to ask that question
because of the reason I've just
articulated it but
and it is it is you know in science you
have to get funding you have to write
research proposals all that kind of
stuff right so there's a degree of you
know as with everything there's a degree
of self-censorship so people only ask
you know scientists are only going to
spend their time writing research you
know funding proposals for things they
think you're going to get funding right
it takes a transfer out of time so it's
a bit of that and there's probably some
of it being turned down because it's
it's a hot potato yeah but you know it's
it's 20 is almost 2020 right it's in a
couple of weeks early 2020 and over the
last if you look over the last say 10
years or 15 years the amount of
knowledge and science has been done into
cognition psychology how our brains work
is extraordinary
I mean it's moved on so much and to not
use that knowledge to our own advantage
seems to me to be crazy I mean something
you said earlier was to what degree are
we aware of this you know there's two
bits to our brain there's the
unconscious bit and there's the
conscious bit and in politics we all
think it's about the conscious bit or
the you know the the policies the what's
the logically right thing to do but
actually as in war you know politics are
more the same thing right they're just
they're on the same spectrum you're just
using violence as a means of
communication rather than using words
and it's the old Clausewitz in war is
the continuation of politics by other
means we think that politics and war can
be understood rationally by you know
doing studies of ideology and all that
kind of stuff for actually the argument
in why we fight and the argument of you
know the evidence that has come out in
the last 10 years of how our brains work
is actually that we're driven by
unconscious things we're not aware of
them and later on our conscious brain
comes and fits a narrative illogical
conscious narrative to that already
decision that that subconscious drive
has already pushed us in that direction
sounds like what's going to happen today
after what you've just described is
Facebook yeah pretty much yeah very much
so but but actually I mean in terms of
the genetic heritability of something
like the predilection for extremism yeah
I mean every other human behavior is to
some extent driven by our genes so it
would be it would be extraordinary if
there was not a genetic component
towards being a suicide mom yeah well
that makes perfect sense and I suppose
the the ethical consideration there is
well if we invent some way of telling
who's a terrorist are we going to start
you know putting them in camps or
whatever you know and and and for other
criminals as well but let me ask you
this because you mentioned the gender
thing and I think one of the most
misunderstood and also fundamentally
unhealthy concepts that has emerged in
recent years is this idea of toxic
masculinity the idea that men are
trained in by society to be violent to
rape to to behave in these way in all of
these ways right but based on what you
are talking about is fundamentally men
from an evolutionary perspective evolved
to engage in violence in certain
contexts Yeah right so what do you make
of this idea that kind of the nurture of
of the way that we nurture men in
society is wrong and bad and that's why
you know we're all toxic and people so
um I want to be really clear that what
I'm about to say is not is not kind of
going well that's the way it is you know
[Music]
and you know Matt's help in our he's
about to say that I'm a I'm a liberal
with a small L right and so what is okay
let's let's go back to you know we've
spoke about testosterone right yeah
and we've also spoken about how
everything is genes x environment yeah
behavioral physical traits
okay so testosterone the average man has
20 times the level of testosterone as
the average woman okay that's that's a
fact we have an overwhelming weight of
evidence that demonstrates that is that
not due to the patriarchy and now of
course you know those bail codes that we
spoke about the male and the female bail
codes will overlap of course which is
where this discussion comes up yeah oh
yeah a trans athletes in sports
yes and it's trans trans women in sports
oh yeah okay but the you see two very
clear Peaks if those are the overlapping
bell curves you see two very clear peace
okay twenty times men have twenty times
yeah and so what does testosterone do
what most people think are testosterone
the core misconception is it makes you
violent and aggressive okay that's not
actually what testosterone testosterone
causes you to seek status
it's the status seeking hormone now it
turns out that being aggressive and
violent a certain percentage of the time
works to help you get status so that's
why people have that's why there's a
common misconception but what it does is
it causes you to seek status and why do
men have twenty times such as Susteren
and women because they're having a high
social status because a polygamy
pays off for men more than it does for
women okay one man many wives is much
more common than one wife or many men
and has been throughout our evolutionary
history so
there's a much higher status payoff for
men in reproductive terms than awful
women the reason for that by the way is
because women are taken out of the
reproduction game here for nine months
right and men are taken out the
reproduction game for ten seconds and so
far in terms of your sex way you need
the map afterwards there so in terms of
your sex ratio yeah there's the women of
the next yeah absolutely
you know that's why men seek States will
have higher levels of substrate so you
know I'm not telling you anything you
don't know everybody knows that men
particular in their seventeen to twenty
five yeah are just puffing yeah that's
what that's what they do they peacock
you know yeah and that's not a only is a
social cliche and the reason is social
cliche is because there's a hormonal
basis for earlier so is that to say that
there are no aspects of say misogynistic
behavior that aren't learnt no of course
there are aspects of misogynistic
behavior that are learnt but there is
also you know genes x environment
there's also a heritage component and an
inherited component of this for the vast
vast vast majority of males on the
planet okay now come back to this other
idea of like unconscious versus
conscious right that's a tussle within
our brains and of course you can bring
up boys for example in a way that
recognizes that they have 20 times on
average the levels of testosterone the
girls do which means they will just puff
and they will peacock and they will do
those things and so you can bring boys
up with that knowledge and this you know
this is what men are risk-takers for
instance and I just think you need to
come back to this idea of why aren't we
talking about this in politics it's not
helpful to say toxic masculinity is a
learned behavior and we all need to
and bring up our children a
gender-neutral way right which I don't
pass any comment on I'm just saying
that's one of the arguments where
actually I think it would be much more
beneficial to say okay there are
actually these differences between men
and women and so we can we can construct
our society in in a very clever way that
gets to the ultimate goal if we agree
that we all want to get to complete
equality between the sexes I find that
it would be much better way to get to
that eventual goal if we say these are
the differences and therefore we
deconstruct our society to get to that
point rather than saying no there are no
differences it's all learn you know to
know to get to where you want to get to
you have to know where you are yeah yeah
and if you think you're in the wrong
place you're not going to get to where
you get where you want to get to and
it's one part of the book that I find
particularly fascinating was how you
were saying that a lot of fights are
caused by a perceived loss of status
yeah between the two combatants so you
know if that they walk away from the
fight they've somehow lost status their
status is diminished and therefore they
have become in inverted commas weaker
yeah I mean the the statistics on this
are stark okay so in criminology 95% of
murders are committed by men yeah of
which about two-thirds of those are what
are called trivial altercations is all
the criminology coming you know category
is and what attributable occasion is is
a fight over a pool table or and the
beauty about this is this and that goes
through time so we had records from the
1200 s in England where people started
fights over games of chess or mistresses
in taverns and stuff it's a you see the
same pattern throughout you know England
has eight hundred years of murder
statistics and stories and judgments so
we have this long long skew of data to
look at it and that is the reason that
men commits and they're also the victims
as well as the perpetrators of the vast
majority of murders because they are the
ones that seek States over each other
because and this is where if you drill
down in statistics you find that not
only is it men but the vast majority of
those men who commit murders are between
the ages of 17 to 30 and they're from
lower rungs lower social success so
they're sort of unemployed maybe they're
literate or poorly educated they don't
have a job but they live in deprived
areas and that's because effectively
what's been triggered in their brain is
I'm in a low part of the social rung so
I need to climb up it and so you see
higher levels of violence and you know
there's so much evidence for this in in
China where the Institute's the
one-child policy they did it region by
regions they didn't do it all at the
same time and of course what the
one-child policy does is it creates
female infanticide because there's a
preference for sons that skews the sex
ratio so where you have the one-child
policy coming in you get more men and
lower women right which means that the
men when they get to 20 are competing
for a smaller that cohort when it comes
to marriage age they're competing for a
smaller number of women and what you see
is a very very small change like naught
point I don't have a statistics like
office off my head but you know point
one or point three percent change in the
sex ratio leads to kind of 5% more
violent crime and murder when that birth
cohort reaches reaches marriage you know
reproduction age that makes so much
sense that makes so much sense I mean
this is obvious stuff it should be
shouldn't it I mean all of the stuff
you're saying it should be part of how
we talk about these things because it
kind of it's just a very logical and
simple explanation of and we've instead
invented all these complicated concepts
that not necessarily add all that
helpful are they you know I you know
there's something called Occam's razor
right yeah which is which is when you're
trying to study a problem you'll come up
with loads of competing theories more
often than not the most simplistic
solution or the one that has the the
fewest assumption leaps in
here is the one that will turn out to be
true and when we're doing stuff like the
patriarchy or in social relations or
theories about war why people fight wars
when the social science tries to unpick
these things because that's when social
science rise from buildings you're
starting with a kind of rational actor
model the people are rational actors
that make decisions that are best there
are the best decisions for them in in
irrational terms are kind of they
benefit the most from those decisions
you have to construct quite elaborate
social models about population level
movements and forces and all that kind
of stuff
whereas and it's very hard to test those
models empirically and to gather data it
looks very hard in social science to get
the data because effectively what you're
trying to do is let's say you're trying
to measure the degree to which an
ideology penetrates in a population
right does ideology drive violence let's
say we're trying to test that right the
answer that you get to that question
will depend entirely on how you define
ideology hmm again it's a questionnaire
we in the Suites but you know how are we
going to define that and how I define
that will give me the answer but in
biology for instance like there's not
many ways that can define testosterone
level like that's it I'll take a blood
sample and I'll do that to 20,000 people
and then I'll come up with you know ten
thousand ten thousand women I'll come up
with you know two bell curves that
overlap but have different medians for
the levels of testosterone it's I don't
wish to disparage the social sciences
but I think there are some questions
where we could to a much greater degree
that there was much more explanatory
power in things like psychology and
biology and you know that I was invited
to give the annual lecture at King's
College London this year at the war
studies department which very kind of
them frankly it was a great honor and
that was
actually the argument that I advanced
which is that there are all sorts of
fields dis scholarship these disciplines
that we can bring to bear on the study
of war and in such relations that give
us a much greater explanation of what's
going on rather than these models that
we constructs that rely on our own
definitions of things that are hard to
kind of pin down empirical models and
you were talking about war and conflict
and so and one of the things that I
found fascinating in why we fight your
book you talk about the fact that when
we construct these complex theories
about why there's conflicts why we do
these things we think of nations as
fighting we think of nations as making
decisions whereas in fact yeah it's a
few unusually men who are making these
decisions right at the top and typically
they are competing for status between
each other and yet
frequently the wars are essentially
caused by chest puffing from these guys
right right right
so so and this is where I think it will
go next right if if we let's say that we
kind of look at these social phenomena
for an individual level right because
I'm a witch on the studying them at a
societal level and that's because we
reach the limits of what we can explain
so let's say we go actually we're gonna
look at it from a from an individual
level you know I don't know we can
measure hormones or we're gonna whatever
unity right like you say it's trying to
identify this sort of status you know
chest puffing then the next challenge
after that is right and we haven't even
got there yet but next challenge after
that is once you've understood the
individual basis for this stuff how do
you then abstract that it's the
population level because you've got
effectively you've got a relationship
between leaders who pursue blog but I
mean but mostly pursue status right
that's the drive that drives leaders
obviously right and you have followers
who are sue States is a bit but mostly
pursuit belonging right so you have this
tension between leaders and followers
and between the driver state symbol
and what followers give leaders is they
fulfill their need for status right
because they create the group that the
leader can lead and what leaders do for
followers is they create the sense of
belonging by articulating a framework
and a narrative for that group which
helps people belong to a group so
there's a there's a you know these these
ideas about you know elites and and how
they are you know just controlling the
masses and like and I saw now there's a
tension between the two like human
society always has this tension and it's
it comes out in politics and it comes
out in war and so the real challenge is
once we reroute Adar self in the
individual how we then abstract that and
try and understand population level how
population level dynamics abstract from
the individual yeah all right well we've
got time for basically our final
question which is running late because
we started late cause of the [ __ ]
election we stayed up until 4:00 a.m.
last night I'm having lunch with my
godmother so I can't be like yeah
exactly the question that we always end
our show is what's the one thing that
we're talking about that we're not
talking about it's a society that we
really should be talking about within
national politics within international
relations within the study of war with
in conflict reduction within terrorism
all of those fields would benefit
greatly from bringing in what we've been
talking about understanding how
evolution how hormonal levels how
unconscious drives actually shape all of
that stuff much more than the rational
actor model that we've hitherto
use to explain those phenomena and that
has huge implications from societal
change around gender debate it has huge
implications for you know the world's
getting unsafe ER and we might be
heading into a global war so
understanding how
those drives are drive conflicts and it
has huge implications for things like
understanding the impact of social media
on disrupting our politics and perhaps
destabilizing political systems which
obviously has you know concurrent
knock-on effects to you know leading
into conflict so we've really got to get
our politics up to speed but the last 10
years of cognitive research fantastic
well I think it's absolutely brilliant
what are you doing what you wrote about
and what you've said today is just is
such a obvious and simple explanations
to explanation to many very complex
problems right but the explanation is
very simple if we were just willing to
look reality in the face so it doesn't
stop you from being deeply problematic
guys make sure you get this book is
absolutely fascinating as you can see
mike is a brilliant guy and very
interesting thank you so much for coming
on the show if people want to follow you
you're on Twitter or anywhere like that
yeah yeah fresh thoughts calm perfect
we'll put that in the links and we will
see you with another britain episode in
a week's time take care guys see you
next week thanks for watching guys as
always subscribe to the YouTube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media ads trigger pod and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word
[Music]